ohne spaß das schmeckt wie chicken
mcnuggets finde ich sind wahrscheinlich
chicken mcnuggets meinen schlimmsten
kann man 15 preisen
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja da hatte ich
hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut mir ist
was ganz interessantes aufgefallen und
zwar irgendwie beginne ich so einen blog
oder ja ich sag mal so wenn ich mit der
sony filme also meinem blog immer so
stimmt in meinem zimmer
ich weiß ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
habe so ein bisschen was vermisst und
zwar kenne viele von euch wahrscheinlich
noch meine essens videos und ihr habt
sie bestimmt auch vermisst und manche
vielleicht auch nicht aber ich selber
auch und ich habe ja schon wirklich sehr
viel gemacht deswegen ist es immer
schwerer auf eine neue idee zu kommen
was irgend was man essen angeht einzige
richtung mcdonalds burger king und so
weiter geht
deswegen ganz wichtig alle euch schreibt
mir doch einfach mal irgendwelche idee
in die kommentare auf was die lust hätte
was ich machen könnte
halt aufessen bezogen weil ich finde
dass ist immer cooler content der mega
spaß macht und ich denke euch auch also
war kommentare würde ich mich sehr
freuen
dann noch ganz wichtig abonnieren nicht
vergessen werden immer mehr das freut
mich sehr
und heute geht es um neue fast food
trends wurde falls man das so nennen
darf
ich habe irgendwann mal angefangen mit
dem video wechseln als produkt du dich
niemand kennt danach kann das video die
neuesten fast food trends von mcdonald's
das gleiche habe ich glaube ich auch
noch mit burger king gemacht ich weiß
schon gar nicht mehr ist schon ein
bisschen her es geht halt noch
irgendwelche neuen produkte die da
angeboten werden von denen man
eigentlich gar nicht so mitbekommt und
da wo man nie auf die idee kommen würde
das bestelle ich mir doch jetzt mal so
sehe ich das zumindest ich meine berge
zu mcdonalds und bestellt sich fünf
shrimps mit mango chili tipp wir fanden
es los ich schaue was ich so bekomme ich
wollte erst ein anderes land zu burger
king und letzte auf
ich würde aber zu sagen ich habe ewig
nicht mehr wirklich so ein menü da
gegessen aber das ist ja eigentlich auch
nicht dass hierüber übermorgen beginnt
übrigens hier in köln die gamescom
bestehen der menge coole veranstaltung
haben da freue ich mich schon sehr drauf
vielleicht sieht man ja den einen oder
anderen freue ich hab mir grad schon mal
einige produkte rausgesucht ablege
screenshot die werden jetzt gleich
bestellen wir fahren als erstem
ecclestone zu burger king und mal sehen
die unter anderem schwind schmecken
wortspiel hallo ich hätte gerne einmal
dass ich muss ein bisschen aufpassen uns
fällt einiges unter wären so ein paar
flüssigkeiten an bord unter anderem
spice geri okay ich habe mir gedacht
bevor ich jetzt zu bergen fahre und das
ganze schmelz probiert das erste mal und
versuche bei berching online zu
bestellen weil das geht ja eigentlich
kann halt nur sein dass es dann erst um
zwei stunden da ist aber ich hoffe mal
nicht also schauen wir einfach mal kurz
rein übrigens morgen gerechnet extrem
cooles video und zwar dort verwerfen und
neue edition diesmal werden die daten
teile einfach den ganzen tag jetzt nicht
nur irgendwelche restaurants entscheiden
sondern halt komplett alles so ist
zumindest gedacht deswegen schaut morgen
auf jeden fall rein amerikanische burger
king aber richtig gutes millionen also
ich muss sagen ich habe jetzt gerade
hier alles mal durchgekocht irgendwie
haben die doch kingfisher
also ich muss sagen entweder bin ich ein
fast food experte oder bergen ist
einfach schlecht also mcdonald's sich
selber oft okay da gibt es wieder was
neues habe ich vorher noch nie gesehen
und man hat das aber überhaupt nicht
erwartet dass es so etwas dagegen habe
ich glaube ich das letzte mal vor einem
halben jahr ein video gedreht und ich
habe absolut keine veränderungen gesehen
vom sortiment hat ist jetzt ein bisschen
blöd aber wir haben ja erst mal vier
produkte dahin so damit herzlich
willkommen ich zeige ich es einfach mal
was ich ausgewählt habe also ich hätte
noch mehr
wir können aber ich glaube das reicht
erst mal hat auch insgesamt elf euro
gekostet ich bin eigentlich am meisten
gespannt ob diese schulen spricht man
das überhaupt so aus also wir haben hier
fünf teams mit mango chili haben dadurch
wirklich vier euro kostet dann was ist
wirklich noch gar nicht lange gibt sieht
aus wie bubble tea ist das spray cherry
oder so ganz kompliziert sieht
eigentlich echt geil aus ich bin mal
gespannt ob das noch spray schmeckt so
dann haben wir hier noch den vanilla
cherry
diese nahm da musste erst mal drauf
kommen auf jeden fall muss ich sagen ich
finde das sieht am geilsten ausschnitt
sahne obendrauf irgendwie so ja wieso
einen milchshake halten und jetzt muss
ich auch sagen ich habe mir das pink ich
habe mir das pink pop geholt ich habe
das eigentlich schon mal probiert oder
das problem war der typen hatte keinen
plan wie man das macht und hatte einfach
irgendwie so schokoladensauce
reingemacht habe ich auch in meiner
instagram story dann alle geschrieben
haben ist das denn keine ahnung war
wahrscheinlich neu da also wir haben
vier produkte ich muss halt sagen
burger king hat nichts neues deswegen
kann ich da jetzt auch nichts bestellen
wir fangen einfach mal hier mit an
wo ist das süß also man muss sagen es
schmeckt erfrischend aber es schmeckt
auch sehr künstlich das ist auf jeden
fall so ein fall
sieger aus als es ist aber ist es gar
nicht schlecht wenn man mit neben ok als
nächstes werden wir den sprit in cherry
/ probieren dann gibt es auch noch in
verschiedene varianten also ich glaub
cola und fanta geht auf ja ich bin echt
mal gespannt
oha da man jetzt weiß dass das breit
sein soll könnte man se rahden aber ist
meiner meinung nach sehr süß dazu kommt
auch noch ein bitterer nachgeschmack ist
jetzt auch nicht so zu 100 prozent
manchmal er überhaupt nicht also was
jetzt bin ich noch nicht so überzeugt
von neuen produkten lässt destination
schaut euch das mal an der verpackung
klebt einfach irgendwie so keine ahnung
was los sein sondern als erstes haben
wir die schweiz mit mango schilde
diesen tipp der ist wirklich gut dann
kann man weiterhin fehlen ihr habe ich
schon öfter mal probiert allerdings noch
nie mit diesen chips hier bin ich jetzt
wirklich sehr gespannt ob man das essen
kann weil ich würde einfach mal sagen
nein definitiv nein
da frage ich mich dann auch wie kommen
die auf eine idee so was mit dem solche
menschen immer gut wenn es lecker ist
kann man es verstehen
[Musik]
bereinigt gar nicht mal so schlecht wie
chicken mcnuggets wurde spaß das
schmeckt wie chicken mcnuggets finde ich
sind wahrscheinlich schicken dann willst
du einfach in schrems kommt kann man
film zu schreiben hätte ich jetzt werde
ich gar nicht gedacht dass sie so gut
schmecken ich hatte die auch letztes mal
ein video von nordsee probiert da finde
ich diese hier sogar eigentlich besser
die frage ist jetzt nur sind es wirklich
schönes oder was ist da alles noch mit
bald keine ahnung kann man aber auf
jeden fall mal essen wenn man keine lust
auf irgendwas gesundes hat und dann
probiere ich jetzt noch mal live das
loch alter hätte man das nicht noch ein
bisschen voller machen können so guten
appetit
[Musik]
die coolen gut
mich erinnert das irgendwie ziemlich
stark kenne dieses kaktus eis dieser
diese grüne schicht dran ist oder was
auch immer da ist
wenn wir mal kurz ein foto ein ich finde
die kügelchen schmecken so ein bisschen
danach ich kann mich gar nicht mehr so
ganz daran erinnern wie das erste eis
von denen da geschmeckt ob das jetzt
besser ist weiß ich nicht diese beiden
getränke hier fand ich nicht so gut
um ehrlich zu sein natürlich trinke ich
darf man noch ein bisschen was das hier
ist echt lecker die schwimmer auch gut
ich warte einfach mal vielleicht kommt
ja in einem halben jahr der nächste
party zu wenn es dann wieder irgendwas
neues gibt zum beispiel als radkappe
kino jerry's bleibt kohler mit macquarie
edition ehrlich diese namen davon die
sind so lang das musst du dir erstmal
sagen am mac treiben damit der kapiert
man sowas schreibt in die kommentare
neue ideen mit essen vielleicht auch
fast keine ahnung seid kreativ genauso
wie ich es versuche zu sein
vielleicht bin ich ja selber was wir
sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen wieder
check der journalist im ab und ist immer
gesund sehr wichtig gesund ernähren so
wie ich habe ein tor